es ist immer noch ein offenes rennen
auch wenn joe biden führt deshalb lasst
uns einmal auf die karte schauen und
zwar erst mal nehmen wir uns joe biden
space to victory also sein weg zum sieg
mit joe biden 270 wahlmänner erreichen
kann um sich so die präsidentschaft zu
sichern
wie man sieht joe biden sieht man jetzt
bei ca 264 wahlmännern und zwar wurde
ihm hier nevada also den wada ist ihm
noch nicht zu gerechnet hier sind noch
sechs offen 264 +6 dann ist ja bei 270
und hat das ding wenn das so bleibt dann
hat er es gewonnen
im prinzip im prinzip steht er ganz kurz
davor also er hat einen ganz klaren weg
zu den 270 bei donald trump sieht das
anders aus er hat erst 214 wahlmänner
das heißt er müsste noch deutlich mehr
staaten gewinnen um auf die 270 zukommen
donald trumps weg führt
erstaunlicherweise nicht nur über
pennsylvania über nord carolina und über
georgia dir auf jeden fall gewinnen muss
nein er muss sich auch ein staat
zurückholen den zumindest fox news
bereits joe biden zugeschlagen hat und
zwar ist das arizona
das erstaunliche ist arizona ist noch
möglich dass es sich in richtung donald
trump entwickelt wenn er arizona also
flippt und die drei staaten gewinnt in
denen er bislang führt dann hat er es
geschafft man sieht also donald trump
hat noch sehr viel vor sich bei joe
biden ist der weg deutlich einfacher und
darüber möchte ich jetzt mit bild
chefredakteur julian reichelt sprechen
julian fangen wir erstmal an mit arizona
da gab es zuletzt sehr spannende
entwicklungen die darauf hindeuten dass
den jump obwohl der bundesstaat von fox
news bereits für beiden ausgerufen wurde
dass donald trump dennoch chancen hat
ihm zu gewinnen ja das faszinierende an
der auszählung und die gerade läuft ist
das vermutlich zum ersten mal in der
geschichte dieser präsidentschaft der
tram präsidentschaft die trump anhänger
voller hoffnung
auf cnn und voller wut auf fox news
gucken das war bisher immer umgekehrt
fox news der sender des trommlers hat
ist nämlich der sender der arizona schon
für das beiden lager ausgerufen hat
während cnn und das müssen wir den
zuschauern einmal erklären
wir benutzen hier als das maßgebliche
für die entscheidung gibt es einen
präsidenten oder nicht die zahlen von
cnn warum ist das so cnn gehörte einem
konsortium an das in den usa mit den
konservativsten methoden also mit den
sichersten methoden am ende errechnet
ist ein staat zugerechnet oder nicht es
hätte press und fox news haben arizona
bereits für joe biden ausgerufen aber da
ist in den letzten stunden etwas
spannendes passiert wenn wir uns einmal
arizona anschauen dann sehen wir hier in
den counties mein körper und hier unten
in pina läuft bisher die auszählung
interessant ist dabei vor allem mario
kopper maricopa wo sich dass die stadt
phoenix befindet hat in den letzten
stunden erstaunlich gut für donald trump
performt 60 prozent der stimmen die hier
noch ausgezählt werden müssen sind in
den letzten stunden an donald trump
gegangen ich glaube es sind noch
ungefähr 56 prozent der stimmen übrig
die dort ausgezählt werden müssen wenn
diese weiteren fünf prozent die noch
ausgezählt werden müssen weiter mit
ungefähr 60 prozent an donald trump
gehen dann wird dieser bundesstaat
arizona nicht wie ursprünglich von
foxnews gecallt an das team von joe
biden gehen sondern dann wird er zurück
fallen an donald trump und das was ich
was wir hier gerade erleben nenne ich
dass die älteren unter uns werden sich
erinnern
pacman phänomen pacman wir erinnern uns
alle knapp knapp knapp war diese kleine
computerspiel figur die langsam diese
pixel auf futtert und das ist das was
wir in den letzten stunden in auf dieser
faszinierenden us- elektro web erlebt
haben dort wo es eigentlich sicher schon
galt oder sicher schien nämlich hier in
arizona und hier in pennsylvania dort
erleben
die größten verschiebung dort knabbern
die beiden kandidaten jeweils dem
anderen kandidaten die prozentpunkte
vector beiden knabbert hier in
pennsylvania an dem ein bisher enormen
vorsprung von donald trump 760.000
stimmen lag donald trump ihr vorne in
der wahlnacht inzwischen wir schauen
jetzt auf den letzten stand sind wir bei
ungefähr 150 stimmen die 150.000 stimmen
die dort vorne liegt warum ist das so
das liegt daran erstens dass wir sehen
dass hier wo es blau ist auf der karte
harrisburg philadelphia und auch
pittsburgh in diesem counties um diese
großstädte wird geradeaus gezählt das
sind tendenziell orte die bestimmen die
demokratisch stimmen es sind aber auch
die bezirke in denen bisher die meisten
briefwahl stimmen abgegeben und die
briefwahlstimmen sind die die gerade
ausgezählt werden das heißt in ohnehin
demokratischen bezirken wo demokraten in
einem besonders hohen anteil briefwahl
gemacht haben werden jetzt erst nach
schließung der wahllokale
diese stimmen ausgewählt und deswegen
knapp aber knapp
knapper und immer mehr stimmen von
donald trump anders lage von joe biden
und dieser vorstoß schmidt zusammen das
gleiche sehen wir aber eben auch noch
einmal zur erinnerung hier in arizona im
umgekehrten effekt dort knabbert donald
trump gerade den eigentlich sicher
geglaubten vorsprung und teilweise schon
ausgerufen den vorsprung von joe biden
weg tja um bei der pacman analogie mal
zu bleiben
joe biden speckmann ist aber deutlich
kraftvoller als der von donald trump
nehmen wir an dass diese beiden staaten
pennsylvania das bislang an trump gehen
sollte und arizona das bislang an beiden
gehen sollte nehmen wir an dass beide
flippen dann ist der große gewinner joe
biden
dann ist der große gewinner joe biden
wir können uns das noch einmal kurz hier
anschauen pennsylvania
da sehen wir 29 elektra awards noch
einmal kurz zur erinnerung für unsere
zuschauer
wir bleiben jetzt bei denen stimmen wir
dies hier in verteilter 253 stimmen für
joe biden damit braucht er noch 17
stimmen
für donald trump damit braucht er noch
57 stimmen so und wenn wir jetzt einmal
zurück auf die karte geben wo könnten
diese 17 stimmen hier kommen die können
entweder aus arizona und nevada kommt
für die beiden zusammen 70 im dax sind
hier die 270 erreicht dann müsste er nur
darauf hoffen dass der donald trump
eckmann hier in arizona nicht allzu
heftig an den vorsprung knabbert also
diese beiden stimmen es würde aber auch
reichen für joe biden
das seien pacman hier mit großer macht
an den stimmen von donald trump knabbert
und die insgesamt gesehen es hier auf
der kart 20 elektra awards er in
pennsylvania erobert damit 253 plus die
20 hier auf der karte während wir dann
bei 273 und damit über der magischen
grenze von 270 das heisst donald trump
muss hier arizona erobern um hier im
osten des landes überhaupt eine chance
zu haben
auf diese über 270 stimmen zu kommen
während joe biden eben mehrere passt
victoria kann diese beiden staaten
nevada arizona gewinnen das würde ihm
schon ausreichen oder er kann im moment
sein wahlkampfteam kann im moment hier
auf die ostküste gucken und auch da ist
es besonders hat nicht nur in
pennsylvania sondern auch zum beispiel
in georgia ist es besonders eng gerade
geworden
wir sehen dass hier 49,6 für donald
trump 49,2 0,4 hauchdünn
auch da wird noch ausgezählt auch da
aber der pacman er an den stimmen von
donald trump und erobert sie zurück für
das lager von joe biden das heißt der
weg von joe biden kann theoretisch auch
führen über nevada und georgia das heißt
wir sehen ganz viele verschiedene
konstellationen die hier für die beiden
noch funktionieren würden während donald
trump noch einmal zwingend hier in
arizona den staat aus den eigentlich für
torben sicher geglaubten staat joe biden
wieder einreißen muss um sich dann hier
dem osten zuzuwenden pennsylvania north
carolina und georgia die drei müsste er
dann alle noch gewinnen
das ist nicht besonders wahrscheinlich
im moment aber es ist auch noch keiner
weise in dem bereich wo wir
den ton den joe biden jetzt angeschlagen
hat im prinzip als neuer präsident schon
durch daten hier hinterlegen können
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren